we've heard today
is sickening to everyone and there are
simply no words
no words at all that can describe the
appalling tragedy around sarah everard's
murder
all our thoughts and our sympathy are
with her family and she's constantly in
my thoughts as well
and in terms of the monster that has
been convicted today it is right that he
is
has been given a whole life tariff and
with that he can never walk the streets
of our country again
and alongside that of course it is right
that we constantly hold the police to
account
for what has happened
and with regards to the whole issue
around the fact that he was a serving
police officer which has been reflected
upon in the judgment today
there are questions serious questions
that will need to be answered by the
metropolitan police
and i would just say further to that
that from the very day that sarah went
missing i had been clearly in contact
with the metropolitan police and putting
forward some questions around the
conduct of
the potential suspect at the time
and all the requirements and the checks
that you know had or should have been
put in place but it's not just his
conduct it's the police's conduct he was
known to his colleagues
as someone who women were uncomfortable
around his colleagues called him
the rapist
what are the questions why is was this
man allowed to be a police officer well
i think first of all these are questions
these are questions for the metropolitan
police and these are questions that have
been asked already i should just be very
clear about that
in my holding of account of the
metropolitan police in previous months
as i said from the minute that sarah
went missing these were clear points and
questions and challenges that were put
to the metropolitan police and to the
met commissioner directly
now i think just on this point in
particular we all have to be very clear
that right now there is a grieving
family and with that there are many
women and girls who simply feel unsafe
as to what has happened and will listen
to what has been said by the judge today
around the abuse of trust and the abuse
of power by a serving officer a serving
officer in the metropolitan police it's
my duty and responsibility to continue
to hold the police to account to
continue to ask the questions that i
have been asking over recent months but
also i think importantly to ensure that
the change that we need to see
within the police actually takes place
and that is clearly why i have
commissioned
our strategy
the inspectorate has produced a report
where we are looking at the findings
right now in terms of what the police
need to do to yes be held to account
be more transparent but fundamentally
change their approach to these issues
around
crimes and violence against women and
girls and that is absolutely essential
to the work that i'm doing
i say this not just as home secretary
but i say this as a woman
all of us want to feel safe and be safe
that is absolutely a right that we have
and with that of course um the police
need to engage in the right way and
they'll be held to account um going
forward that's very general what are the
questions you're asking and what is the
change you want to see well i think
first of all you're asking questions
specific to this case i have asked
questions and these have been ongoing
around issues around the conduct the
abuse of power we have heard very
clearly today from the judge of this
monster abusing his position of
authority the power and the trust that
he had as a serving police officer
that should not have happened and with
that of course
there are wider issues around public
confidence that will need to be
addressed and it's right that the
metropolitan police address those
concerns should the commissioner resign
is she the person to oversee that change
well i think first of all there are
important questions and questions that
i've been asking and challenges we have
to be honest about this
in particular to this case but also the
conduct of that serving officer and
conduct a policy more broadly so i will
continue to work with the metropolitan
police and the commissioner to hold them
to account as everybody would expect me
to do
and i will continue to do that